نقف في المناطق الشماليه لمنطقه الرمال
وهذه المنطقه هي منطقه دوار فلسطين التي
نصفت على ايدي قوات الاحتلال يوم امس هذه
المنطقه التي تغيرت معالمها بشكل كامل
بنايات سكنيه نصفت عشرات العائلات ومئات
العائلات دمرت احلامها بفعل قوات الاحتلال
هذه البنايات السكنيه كانت من اجمل
البنايات السكنيه الموجوده في مدينه غزه
وهذا الحي هو من ارقى الاحياء المتواجده
في مدينه غزه حي الرمال الذي يتمتع بهدوءه
و جمال اماكنه وجمال منطقته الان هو اصبح
حي مدمر في كافه الاماكن لكن هذه المنطقه
التي برزت في الدمار الكبير بعد تفجير
قوات الاحتلال لها بشكل كامل يعني هذا
الحي الان عمارات سكنيه ليس لها اي معالم
الشوارع المناطق هذا الحي الان هو مدمر
بالكامل زلزال هذا اجرام العدو الصهيوني
ناس مدنيين امنين هذه كلها بيوت لا فيها
مراكز قياده ولا في فيها شيء عمارات سكنيه
كلنا سكان في هذه المنطقه اولادنا ونسونا
عايشين مع بعض ايش نا في كل هذا هيك هيك
تعمل دمار 77 يوم مش عارفين مش عارفين
ندوق النوم لا ميه لا اكل لا امان
لاطفالنا الاولاد بطلوا قادرين يعيشوا
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل في الواقع الصوره
يعني تصف المشهد وقد يكون هناك يعني صوره
اوضح واكبر من هذا
الدمار يعني هو في البدايه الحمد لله رب
العالمين على انه احنا طلعنا سالمين
اجمالا حي زي ما انت شايف زلزال طوفان
اكثر من زلزال حتى يعني مش عارف ايش تقول
الدمار الاسرائيلي العدو ابدا بنفس الوقت
يعني اليوم انت بتفاوض مع عدو مش قادر
تعمل شيء دول عربيه دول اسلاميه مش واقفه
معك ما حد واقف معك يعني انت اليوم دمار
شامل احنا عشان تكون في الصوره قبل
اسبوعين كنا في العماره وفجاه فاجئونا
برجليه طلعوا نزلونا من العماره واعتقلوه
اعتقلنا ليله كامله وطردوا النسوان
ويعني وجردوني من الملابس بس على قد ستر
العوره فقط واخذوا كل شيء معنا لغايه
امبارح لغايه امبارح كنا نيجي نطل من بعيد
يعني ها مطمنين لما سمعنا الليله في
الجزيره انه تدمر حي كامل صرنا يعني
نتحايل على نفسنا لا اكيد مش احنا اكيد مش
احنا لما جينا الصبح حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل على العدو
الاسرائيلي على كل من كان سبب الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم يقول ولا تتمنوا القاء
العدو احنا ما حد مدور ولا حد سائل ولا
امم متحده ولا امريكا ولا غيره ولا الدول
المطبعه حتى هذه المنطقه الغربيه التي نقف
بها من المنطقه التي نصفت وهي منطقه دوار
فلسطين اللي واقعه في المناطق الشماليه
لحي الرمال هذه بنايات ايضا دمرت بشكل
كامل وبشكل واضح سويت بالارض لكن نتحدث
اكثر عن هذا الجرح وهذا الالم بعد ان قدم
المواطنون الى هذا المكان
يتعرفوا على بيوتهم لكن يبدو ان الواقع
كان صعب وصادم ولم يتعرف احد على هذه
المعالم من المنطقه مش عارف احنا ممكن
الكلمات اللي
بختارها اخواننا العرب المسلمين فهموها او
في
مشكله حتى لو في مشكله في الكلام الصوره
هي ابلغ من كل
حاجه لكن للاسف الشديد ما فيش اي حدا من
العالم كله قاعد بطلع عنه y